[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICK BRADY: I'm Patrick Brady
from the Android Auto team.
And I'm here with
Lauren, Rasekh, and Dean
to give you an update
on Android in cars.
We've got a lot to cover today
and a lot of automotive puns.
So let's buckle up
and get driving.
We're incredibly excited
about the automotive space
right now because
we see it going
through huge
transformations, from
electrification to
connectivity, sensors and input
devices, sharing and autonomy.
Cars are rapidly turning into
full-blown computers on wheels,
with high-speed mobile
connections, microphones,
cameras, and screens everywhere
of all shapes and sizes.
It's a computing transformation
unlike many we've seen before.
And it opens up
new opportunities
for innovation and
for developers.
Android Auto is an effort
from Google and our partners
to bring these advances
together and create
a safe and seamless connected
experience for drivers
everywhere.
Of course, that's a lot
easier said than done.
There are dozens of
different car platforms
today, many different
input types,
from touch screens to touch
pads and rotary controllers,
many different screen shapes,
and sizes, and resolutions.
Layer on top of that the
myriad driver distraction
guidelines and regulations
across the globe.
If every software
developer had to deal
with this level
of complexity, we
would never be able to realize
the potential that automotive
holds.
Well, at Google, we
believe that platforms
can reduce that complexity and
allow developers to just focus
on innovation.
We saw that happen on
the web and in mobile.
And we're working hard to
do the same thing here,
making Android the
platform for the car.
Today, you can see that
vision at work in any Android
Auto-compatible car.
Drivers have access
to their favorite apps
right from the car's display.
And developers build their
app once for every car,
without having to worry about
the make and model, the screen
size, the input type.
We started this
journey back in 2014,
partnering with
leading car brands
to bring Android
Auto to their cars.
We've made a lot of
progress since then,
and I'd like to give you
just a quick update on how
things are going.
We continue to see incredible
growth in compatible cars
and aftermarket systems,
with over 500 models
available today from
50 different brands.
Since last I/O, we've seen
first launches from Fiat,
Alfa Romeo, Tata Motors,
and Smart; and 2018,
bringing exciting new launches
from Jaguar, Land Rover, Mazda,
and many more.
Just last month, JVC and Kenwood
launched the first head unit
supporting Android
Auto wireless.
We're really excited
about wireless,
and we look forward to more
partner launches in the months
ahead.
With these great partnerships,
we're well on our way to
making Android the platform,
the developer platform,
for every new car shipped.
But what about the 1 billion
cars on the road that
predated Android Auto?
What do we do for those cars?
Well, of course, we
know not everyone
has a compatible vehicle.
So we made the Android Auto app
available to all Android users
as a standalone experience.
And this opens up the
platform and the ecosystem
to many millions of drivers,
no matter what kind of car
they drive.
And as we've made Android Auto
available to more cars and more
drivers, we're happy to
say that the strong user
growth continues.
Here's where we
were in I/O 2016,
I/O 2017, and
today, at I/O 2018.
We've seen over 300% user
growth in the last year alone.
In fact, as you can
see on the chart,
our growth is
accelerating as we make
Android Auto available to
more cars and more drivers.
And that consistent platform
and large install base
is a great opportunity
for developers.
So we continue to see strong
growth on that front, as well.
In the last year,
with some popular apps
like Waze, Google Play Books,
TextMe, Sirius XM, and Plex
launching Android
Auto, Google Play
now has thousands of
Android Auto apps available.
And that's a 200%
growth from last year.
In January, we also launched
the Google Assistant
in Android Auto, opening
up a new way for drivers
to stay safely connected in
the car and for developers
to build car-friendly
experiences.
And the great thing is actions
built for the Google Assistant
work across the
Assistant services,
from smart speakers to
TVs, wearables, and mobile.
We're excited about some of the
early favorites in automotive,
such as Spot Hero, which
helps you find and reserve
parking spots; busuu, bringing
personalized language learning
right into your car;
and CNBC, bringing you
the most up-to-date
business news and market
insights on the go.
The Actions on Google
ecosystem is exploding,
and we're super excited to
see what you all build next.
But of course, that's just the
beginning for Android in cars.
As cars advance, we
have the opportunity
to create an even more seamless
experience by building Android
right into the car itself.
And that's why we started
an effort back in 2016
to build automotive support
right into the platform.
The first demo of that work
was right here at I/O in 2016
with this concept Maserati.
With a lot of help
from the industry,
we're investing in building
automotive features
into each Android release,
making Android a turnkey
platform for infotainment,
just as it's been
a turnkey solution for phones.
And the rest of the
industry is taking notice.
Last year, two of the world's
most innovative car makers,
Audi and Volvo, announced
that Android will power
their future in-car experiences.
If you had a chance to see
the in-car demos last year,
we think you'll understand
our excitement for the future
and why we look forward
to many more car makers
following in their tracks.
Earlier this week,
Volvo and Google
announced a partnership
to bring Google services
to the next-generation,
Android-powered Volvo cars.
With the Google Assistant,
Google Maps, and the Play Store
seamlessly integrated
into the Sensus system,
were creating a new benchmark
for the connected driving
experience and a
great opportunity
for all of you, our developers.
And of course, this all works
no matter what kind of phone
the driver has, or even if
they leave their phone at home.
To get a preview of
that experience today,
swing by the Android
Auto Sandbox,
where you can see it live and
in action in the next C40.
So we've made a lot of progress
since Android Auto first
hit the road.
And we're well on our way
to establishing Android
as the platform for automotive
in old cars, new cars,
and the next generation of
cars coming up the road ahead.
But of course, it's not enough
to just make Android available
everywhere.
We're also working
hard to make sure it's
the best possible experience for
our users and our developers.
We've listened to them a
lot over the last year,
talking with great developers,
like Spotify and others,
to hear what they want to
see from Android Auto next.
And today, I'd like to give
you a sneak peek at some
of the exciting
changes we're making
and what it means for
the developer community.
So now, I'd like
to invite up Lauren
to tell us where
Android is going next.
[APPLAUSE]
LAUREN WUNDERLICH: Good
morning, and hello, everyone.
My name is Lauren.
I'm going to be speaking about
some of the new challenges
we are facing on the auto space
and how we're adjusting them.
We've spoken before about
why we building Android Auto.
And at the core
of our experience
is our overarching commitment
to bringing a safe and connected
experience to every vehicle.
This is particularly important,
as the primary responsibility
of the driver is to drive.
Everything else we
do is secondary.
To really highlight
this, we showed a photo
of a driver playing Pokemon
Go during one of our research
sessions.
Don't worry, everyone was safe.
We were parked.
But this extreme example
showcases the struggle
we face while balancing
the tension we
feel between balancing our
digital and our physical lives.
By developing strategies
to manage attention,
we can provide a safer
in-car experience
to keep drivers connected.
And as you heard
from Patrick, screens
are getting bigger, wider,
taller, more shapes, and more
inputs, such as touchpad.
We are starting to think about
how to evolve our UI to better
scale and adapt for the future.
The best part is,
as developers, you
don't have to worry about these
layout changes, display size
variants, or even supporting
those input mechanisms,
because the Android
Auto platform takes
on these challenges for you.
Furthermore, we're
looking to see where
Android Auto is going next.
As part of our commitment to
developing the best possible
in-vehicle experience,
we are developing
a built-in experience that feels
more at home in the cockpit.
So I'd like to introduce our
new Google In-Car Concept.
From design's point of view,
the goal of this concept
is to adopt Android
Auto's design
to a vehicle-specific theme.
This includes additional
ergonomic details
and nods to the vehicle's
interior design.
We can leverage these
vehicle concepts to prove out
new features and designs,
working with our partners
to bring them to life.
And besides abstracting
hardware complexity,
we're also thinking about how
to enhance our core experiences
and introduce new ways
to promote your content.
Today, we'll be highlighting
some of the updates
to messaging and
media experiences.
But be sure to stay
tuned as we roll out
all of these updates this year.
For a live demo
of these vehicles,
including a preview of
this onscreen experience,
stop over to the
Android Auto Sandbox.
As part of helping
drivers stay connected,
with user interfaces that are
safer and more predictable,
we have developed
multiple ways for you
to integrate with
Android Auto, depending
on the nature of your service.
For navigation apps,
we work directly
with developers to ensure they
follow our strict distraction
guidelines.
And you can also integrate
with the Google Assistant,
which is voice-centric
and ideal for in-car use.
Be sure to check out their
sessions this year at I/O.
Messaging and media make up
the largest number of apps.
And today, we'll be speaking
about the updates we've made
to both of those experiences.
So let's dive in.
Beginning with messaging
updates, communication apps,
like WhatsApp,
Telegram, and Messages,
integrate with a
messaging template
and are displayed
via notifications.
Notifications
require less effort
and are highly visible
throughout the experience.
We've improved the
notification layer this year,
including more and
unified actions.
More and unified actions
across the surfaces
help drivers react
to incoming content
without ever leaving
their current experience.
And group messaging, a
feature developers and drivers
have been asking for--
now you can stay connected
with multiple people
at the same time.
Media apps, like Spotify,
Pandora, Pocket Casts,
and iHeartRadio, integrate
with the media template.
The template is
designed to remove
these complexities,
such as input,
screen sizes, and orientations.
And they're also designed with
the industry's best practices,
promoting predictability
for drivers
across all of our
systems, including
the phone screen, car display,
and built-in experiences.
We are thrilled to showcase some
of the biggest redesigns we've
made to the media experience
since launching Android Auto.
By focusing on these
three key areas--
media template-- we
have personalized
a modern, content-forward
experience
for all of our drivers.
New architecture, more flexible
UI components, and new search
capabilities make up the
majority of our updates.
So let's dive in--
new architecture.
Before, when drivers
got going, they
would have to navigate to the
media section, open the drawer,
and find that very
special commute playlist.
Now, when a driver gets
going, they no longer
have to seek out the
content they wish to play,
but the content is brought
forward in a very visual way.
We've re-architectured the
media template in order
to pull the content
out of the drawer.
Drivers can easily see content,
saving additional taps,
and getting on the
road just faster.
Our new foundation has created
many more opportunities for you
to showcase content,
for which we've
introduced more components
to promote a new flexibility
and ability to express your
content in a more familiar way
that is native to the app.
Now, you can create more
customized layouts with list
views and subheadings,
as well as
grid views with really large
graphics, additional, richer
metadata hints, such as explicit
content tags, downloaded tags,
and new and in progress tags.
With the added benefit
of the template approach,
each of these new additions are
available regardless of theme.
From the Android on the
phone or on a screen up,
as well as customized
by the OEM,
your branding and layouts
will be respected.
See firsthand how we're doing
that with the Google In-Car
Concept at the Android Sandbox.
Our last major update showcases
a new search and pivot
functionality.
Search is still hands free.
And when a driver asks for
a specific song or artist,
it just begins playing.
In addition to playing the
best-matched song or artist
automatically,
drivers can now pivot
into the app for app-provided
content and related
suggestions.
With the new search
functionality,
we've further optimized
the search results
to include more
digestible format.
Things like subheadings
and subgroups
help drivers find
the content they're
looking for even faster.
So that's what we've
been working on
to enable a healthy
in-car ecosystem.
I've showcased the new messaging
updates and media updates
by focusing on the new
structure, new components,
and more search capabilities.
So I'd like to turn
it over to Rasekh
to teach you how to get
started with these new updates.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
RASEKH RIFAAT: Thanks, Lauren.
Hi, I'm Rasekh, and--
oh, there we go--
I'm here to talk to you
about what developers
need to do to support our
new messaging and media app
features.
Today, I'll go through
some code examples that
will let messaging apps use
support group notifications
and using MessagingStyle.
I'll also go over our
media architecture
and show you how to provide
those in-app search results
that Lauren just mentioned.
And then finally, I'll
look at code changes
for media apps to enable our
content browsing visuals.
Let's start with an example.
So I live in Seattle.
And one of the best things
to do on the weekend--
grab a group of friends
and head out to the hills
to hit the slopes.
Let's use that as
our example today.
Luckily, all of us are using
Android Auto in the car.
And we can start to-- we can
interact with it by voice,
keeping our hands on the wheel
and our eyes on the road.
But we need to coordinate
things, like breakfast, gas,
and just our general progress.
When Android Auto started
supporting messaging,
there wasn't a standard way
to do messaging notifications
on Android.
We introduced Car
Extender helper class
for one-on-one conversations.
But Android notifications have
come a long way since then.
MessagingStyle is a newer,
standard helper class
for generating large-format
notifications that
include multiple back-and-forth
messages of varying types
between any number of people.
You should already be using
it to write rich notifications
on mobile devices today.
And enabling
Android Auto support
is a few short changes
away from that.
So let's take a
look at some code.
So here's Stephan asking, which
run are we going to hit first?
All right, we set that up in our
MessagingStyle as the message.
We set our conversation
title, Ski Trip.
And since it's a
group conversation,
we set that to be true.
Next, we set up
our reply action.
We use a semantic action, which
is new to Messaging Style.
This allows Android Auto
and the Google Assistant
to know what they should be
sending to the pending intent.
After the Google Assistant
has recognized your voice
and composed your reply, it
can launch the messaging app
to send that reply.
Next, we'll create a
Mark As Read action.
You can imagine a scenario
where I'm in the car,
and I listen to my message,
but I don't really--
I'm not really
ready to reply yet.
This gives the
messaging app a callback
to say, oh, the user read this.
Mark it as read and
let other participants
in the conversation know.
Finally, we bring
all that together
in a standard way with
Android notifications.
We had our reply action,
our MessagingStyle,
and our Mark As Read action.
And the Mark As Read
action won't show up
in the standard Android UI.
And we can see the final
result. Our conversation title
is set up.
The group messaging
icons are all
set up from the notification.
And then Assistant
and Android Auto
know that you can
reply by voice.
And even if you just
listen to the message,
we can tell the
other participants
in the conversation
that they've seen it.
So now that we've
coordinated with everyone,
we've figured out
where we're going,
we want to listen to
something on the way
out to the mountains, all right?
Media in the car is one of
the core user experiences.
And getting drivers
access to their content
should be front and center.
Now, for media apps to
integrate with Android Auto,
they have to implement
two services.
The MediaBrowserService
provides a tree
of playable and browsable items.
And browsable
items are basically
folders to help apps organize
their content so they're not
returning a giant list
of songs or podcasts.
Once a user has picked something
playable from the Browse tree,
the Media Session Service,
which the app implements,
is used to start music and to
provide metadata and controls
for what's currently playing.
You can see, in this
example, the app
supports play, pause, skip
to next, skip previous.
And there's also a mechanism
for setting up custom actions--
things like a 30-second skip.
Once a media app has
implemented these two services,
the Google Assistant just
works out of the box.
They say, hey, Google,
play my ski jams.
The Google Assistant will
recognize your voice,
issue the query, and music
starts playing right away.
What we're introducing today
for our in-app searching is
the ability to implement
an extra function
on the MediaBrowserService
to get those in-app results--
MediaBrowserService on search.
In this case, the app has
surfaced my ski jams from 2018,
as well as my playlist from
my skiing trip last year.
Awesome.
Now, let's look at the
code to make this happen.
So for apps which already
support Android Auto,
this is actually
really familiar.
You have a function
which has issued
the query, an extras
bundle, and a destination
for the result.
Let's break it down.
First off, apps should
just return an empty list
if they can't support
the query, OK?
If the thing is
like an empty query,
just return an empty list.
Normally, queries
actually require
a network call or
a database fetch.
And so if that's
the case, and you
want to do work on an extra--
on a different thread,
detach the results, do the
work on that other thread,
and then, when you're
ready, send the results
back to Android Auto.
I want to mention that
these code snippets actually
come from the Universal Music
Player, an open-source media
app published by
Google on GitHub.
It can easily be
cloned, compiled,
and it's a great reference
for creating a media
app across Android Auto
and other surfaces.
So now, we've got
our search results--
our Ski Trip 2018,
2017, and Ski Jams.
Notice that it returned
two playlists, as well
as some albums.
It would be really nice if
Android Auto could group those.
We have a way to
do that, though.
In this function, we're
creating media items
for sending back
to Android Auto.
And it's very easy to
annotate immediate item
with a group heading.
Android Auto will look at
successive media items,
and if they're in
the same category,
will group them together.
So if we annotate our
Ski Jams with playlist,
and our albums with albums,
Android Auto groups them
and shows that for
you, regardless
of screen size and surface.
We're also adding a
couple more annotations,
as Lauren mentioned.
Here, I'm showing the
explicit annotation.
It's great.
I'm in the car.
I got my family.
I don't want that
explicit song to come up.
Also, we're adding a
support for downloaded.
That way, I'm in the mountains,
I don't have good cell
coverage, or I don't want to
burn my data plan on music,
I have a chance to pick
the right playlist.
Android Auto shows them
right with the content.
Looks like Ski Trip 2018 is
the right playlist for my trip.
There's one more
function that needs
updating to take advantage
of these new features.
When the
MediaBrowserService starts,
it provides Android Auto with
a media route and extras.
In order for search and
bringing content out of a drawer
to be enabled, you'll need
to add a couple of extras
to let Android Auto know that
you support these features.
Now, Lauren
introduced the concept
of bringing content out and
being able to show things
as grids or lists.
And by default,
Android Auto will
show browsable
items, the folders,
as lists, because they
generally have an icon.
And they'll show content,
or playable items,
as grids, because they're
usually much richer
and have a much more
detailed artwork.
But there are times when it's
better to switch that around.
So for instance, let's
say you have a podcast up.
In that case, the podcasts,
which are browsable items,
have a much richer
artwork, right?
But all the episodes, which
share the same artwork,
you want to see more about
their detail in a list format.
We're giving you the
ability to choose that
by adding an extra hint in
your on route so that you
can switch the order around and
choose grids or lists depending
on the content in
your media app.
So to sum up, I've
shown code samples
for MessagingStyle,
MediaBrowserService, onSearch,
specifying additional
item metadata,
adding content browsing,
and search hints.
I'm excited to see
developers access
these features in the future.
And look for our documentation
later in the summer.
Now, please welcome Dean
up to talk about tools
for Android Auto development.
[APPLAUSE]
DEAN HARDING: Thanks, Rasekh.
Hi, everyone.
So as Rasekh mentioned,
I'm here to talk to you
about the tools we provide
for developing and testing
your media and
messaging apps, and also
to give you some hints
and tips to help you
make the most of the platform.
The first thing I want to talk
about is the Desktop Head Unit.
This tool is ideal for testing
both your messaging and media
apps, as it will render
your apps exactly the same
as you'd see them in production.
And just as
importantly, it allows
you to interact
with the Assistant,
just like in a real car.
You get the Desktop Head Unit
as part of the Android SDK.
Just select it from
the Download Manager.
The instructions for running
the Desktop Head Unit
are on the developer site,
but it's fairly easy.
Just start the Head Unit Server
from Android Auto's developer
menu on the phone.
You get that by going to
About, then tapping 10 times
on the About Android Auto
header to enable developer mode.
Then, choose Start Head Unit
Server from the overflow menu
that you can see here.
Plug your phone into a
USB port on the computer
and launch the
Desktop Head Unit.
From there, you can see
how Android Auto will
respond to your
app's notifications,
and also, how your media app
will appear in an actual car.
But if you're
developing a media app,
I encourage you to check out the
Android Media Controller, which
is an open-source app that
we have hosted on GitHub.
It will connect to your app's
media session and media browse
service and shows
the information
your app is
presenting to Android
Auto in a nice semantic format.
If you're whitelisting to block
apps other than Android Auto
from accessing your
browse tree, it
would probably be a good
idea to either add the media
controller to the whitelist
or disable the whitelist while
testing.
Rasekh also briefly touched
on the Universal Media Player.
But I wanted to
reiterate that we
have this great,
comprehensive sample media
app available on GitHub.
It gives you a
canonical implementation
of a media app, not
only on Android Auto,
but also on all our other
services, such as Wear and TV.
Let's get into some code now.
The first bit of code
I wanted to talk about
was the standard actions
that your app returns
as part of the playback state.
You should try to make
sure your app supports
the standard actions defined
in PlaybackStateCompact,
such as ACTION_SKIP_TO_NEXT
and ACTION_REWIND.
By using the standard
actions, you not only
have a great integration
with Android Auto,
but you also get
Assistant integration
with those actions for free--
actions like, OK,
Google, skip tracks.
And as we bring Android
Auto to more surfaces,
it may not be the case that
those custom actions appear
in the same place they do today.
But you can be sure the standard
actions are kept in a place
where it makes the most sense.
You can use the
media controller app
to see what standard
actions you've implemented,
and also to see
what's available.
You can see here that
we have an app that
does not implement a standard
forwards, backwards action,
but has instead chosen to
implement those actions
as custom actions.
Now, if you were to look at this
app in the Desktop Head Unit,
you might not necessarily know
that there's anything wrong.
Because of the way we
render the custom actions,
everything looks OK.
But by implementing those
actions as standard actions,
like this, we can leave
the custom actions
for truly custom functionality.
We've done a lot of
research with users
and found that users
do not want to have
to browse while driving.
Here are a few quotes from
some of our research sessions,
where users talk about
some of the issues
that they have with
custom search and browse.
Users typically want to get
in and go without much fuss,
and this is a great
opportunity for you
to provide some additional
value to your users
by giving them easy access
to the playlists they like
or to recommend new
content that they may not
have known about otherwise.
So I would suggest
that you prioritize
surfacing things in the browse
tree with items most relevant
to driving at the top.
Rasekh showed you earlier
some of the things
we're doing to bring
content out of the drawer
and put it front and center.
And you'll definitely want
that first page of content
to be the most useful.
Now, that's not to
say you can't include
all the user's playlists, or
whatever, in the browse tree.
Just keep in mind that the first
few items on your home page
should be the most relevant
to the task of driving.
A corollary to that would
be to keep your browse tree
shallow, no more than
two or three levels deep.
In fact, to make the most of
the new design we've shown you,
a two-level-deep
browse tree is ideal,
because then, your users
will be able to get
to their favorite music or
podcasts with a single tap.
You can use the onSearch method
that Rasekh described earlier
to allow users to search
for specific things,
like a particular song
or a particular artist.
One of the challenges
we have in Android Auto
is that it is used on devices
with many different screen
sizes and resolutions.
Your app isn't
necessarily going to know,
until the moment it's
plugged into a car, what
the resolution of the
screen it's displayed on is,
which means that it's
difficult to predict
what resolution your icons
need to be to look right
on any particular screen.
You can see here, this star
icon is too low resolution
for this display, and
it really looks out
of place with the
rest of the icons.
So package your icons in
the vector graphics format,
rather than a bitmap format.
Vector drawables have been
supported natively in Android
since API level 21,
which, coincidentally,
is the version of Android
that Android Auto support was
introduced.
So there's no reason not to
use the native vector format.
You can see here an
example of the star icon
from before as a vector graphic.
And no matter how
big I make the icon,
it still has nice, smooth edges.
As an added bonus, the
file size of this icon
is really small,
especially compared
to having multiple bitmaps
at different resolutions.
Don't forget, you can use
Android Studio's Vector Asset
tool to convert your SVGs to
the native Android format.
While we're on the
topic of icons,
you should prefer using
the URI-based methods
for passing us your
media, rather than
the drawable-based methods.
This example shows returning
one of your built-in resources
as a URI rather than a drawable.
Using URIs allows us
to case your resources
and to only allocate
memory for the items
that we are actually
physically displaying.
If the user never scrolls
down to the fourth page,
there's no need to allocate
memory for the items
down there.
I also wanted to
briefly touch on
something we've seen
with ad-supported apps.
Typically, the adds
will include some call
to action that may not make
sense when running in the car.
For instance, they might say,
tap the screen to learn more,
or click here, or something
along those lines.
If you're running
inside Android Auto,
I recommend adjusting
your messaging
so that it's not confusing
for people not actually using
your main app's UI.
And lastly, the process of
actually getting your app
onto the Play Store--
once you've added this metadata
snippet to your manifest,
and you've uploaded your
app to the Play Store,
it will need to be reviewed
against our Driver Distraction
Guidelines.
This is a fairly
complicated process,
but the guidelines for
ensuring a smooth review
are documented in the
developer center at this link.
If our reviewers find issues,
you'll be notified by email
and will be able to
resubmit an updated
application for re-review.
So I've gone over
a few things we've
learned over the years
developing for Android Auto.
We've got a great resource
in the Media Controller
for testing media apps.
And don't forget to check
out the Universal Media
Player for a comprehensive
example implementation.
Use the standard actions
where it makes sense,
and leave custom
actions for things
that are actually custom.
Surface the important
actions at the top in browse.
And use search for
finding specific content,
like a particular song
or a particular album.
Keep the browse tree
shallow, no more than two
or three levels deep.
Use vector graphics for icons.
And use the URI-based
methods rather
than sending raw bitmaps.
And finally, be aware
of the surface you're
playing on for ads.
And now, I'd like
to hand it back over
to Patrick for our wrap-up.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK BRADY: Yeah, thanks.
Thanks, Dean.
So today, we showed
you how we're
working to make Android
the platform for developers
in automotive and
how you can develop
your apps on that platform.
We also showcased a new design
for Android Auto in your apps
across surfaces, from old
cars to new, and new developer
APIs that enable your
apps to take advantage
of these new designs
and features,
including MessagingStyle for
group messaging and custom
actions, media
browse enhancements
to bring your content forward
and annotate it with rich media
metadata, and media in-app
search to help your users
find the content they're
looking for across your catalog.
Of course, that's
just a sneak preview
of all the developer resources.
If you'd like more information
to help you update your apps,
please visit the Android
Auto Developer site
at developer.android.com/auto.
And I'd also encourage you to
take a look at the Universal
Media Player and Android
Media Controller examples
that Rasekh and Dean
mentioned, which
are freely available as
open-source software on GitHub.
And while you're
here, you can also
stop by the Android
Team office hours, which
are happening again on
Thursday at 2:30 PM,
to chat with the Android
engineers and business
development teams and ask
them questions directly.
But if you really want to
see these things in action,
please come and check out
the Android Auto Sandbox,
which is just around the
corner, where you can see
the new Android Auto design.
And I promise you,
it's not as janky.
It seems like we were
having some AV issues
with the animations earlier.
But you can see the new
design operating fluidly
in a new Range Rover Velar,
on a beautiful, wide screen,
showing simultaneous
maps and media on the UI
at the same time.
It's really, we think,
a fantastic experience.
You can also find the
Google In-Car Concept
that Lauren talked about,
which is showing the default
experience in Android
that we're making
available as open-source
software in Android
P, and of course, the
latest in-car experience
from our collaboration
with Volvo
in the new Android-powered
Sensus Connect system,
running the Google Assistant,
Google Maps, and the Google
Play Store.
Last but not least, as
with every session at I/O,
we want to--
we value your
feedback, and we want
to hear from you so we can make
our sessions better every year.
So please grab a browser and
swing by google.com/io/schedule
to fill out a short survey
when you have time and leave
your feedback.
Thanks very much,
and have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]